we've announced two things and the most
important reason why we are doing these
two things I'll tell you in a minute is
to make this a simpler more focused and
more agile organization to ultimately
continue to build the long-term
shareholder value that we have done and
the two things that we have announced
this first move into three divisions two
of them will be located in the UK the
beauty and personal care division as
well as the home care division which
until say or ensures a 1 billion pound
investment in the UK and then the second
thing that we have announced is to
simplify our legal structure into one
simple of structure in the Netherlands
the timing is right we've looked at this
for now over a year year and a half have
studied all the angles of it and and
think we've come to the right conclusion
at the right time
and why has the Netherlands won out over
the UK well on the technical grounds for
the legal structure which again I repeat
is a small legal headquarters as most of
our work and people will be in the
divisions really for very simple
technical reasons we have 55% of the
company in the Netherlands with more
than euros there's higher liquidity
there we're trading at a premium so from
our shareholder prospective point of
view it all became easier the optics of
this are pretty terrible for Teresa
mayor she tries to convince the world to
invest in post brexit Britain well I
would say to that look at the
announcement we are having the two
biggest divisions here we are
guaranteeing or securing the 1 billion
pound investment we're actually opening
a big advanced manufacturing facility at
the world together was Liverpool
University which is a 65 million pound
investment so we think that this country
is a really an attractive country for
investment as is the Netherlands for
that matter and our announcement today
will probably lend credibility to that
but this is symbolic isn't it we will
continue to keep our operations of his
knee and
our building here in Blackfriars the two
main divisions will be there it will not
affect the number of people there so
what we're really talking about is a
legal structure that not that doesn't
really also in our company affect many
people you're telling me handled hearts
this has nothing to do with brexit
categorically nothing to do with it we
look at these things for the next 30 to
50 years and as you have seen we have
committed major investments in the UK
related to this announcement and just to
be categorically clear this will not
result in job losses in the UK you
rather see this reorganization as a vote
of confidence in the UK I would
definitely argue that that it is a form
of confidence in the UK just like we are
operating in many countries that are
outside of Europe
we're in 90 countries globally and
there's no reason why the UK itself is
not an attractive investment climate we
do find that an attractive environment
just like we do the Netherlands and and
we've shown that by putting the two
divisions here what people need to
realize is that we have the choice to
put these divisions anywhere could have
put them in the US we could have put
them in the Far East for that matter we
decided to put it in in the UK and I
think you could not have a higher
thought of confidence and we've also
made clear that related to that that we
don't see any changes in in jobs in this
country of course the takeover
protection in the Netherlands is far
tougher than it is here in the UK you
fought off a bit last year from Kraft
Heinz has that been a factor well we've
looked at the corporate governance codes
and both countries the UK as well as the
Netherlands fall actually under the UK
takeover directive and as a result these
legislations are fairly similar you look
at article 172 year of the takeover
Court which is evolving also with the
direction the government is taking and
you look at the Netherlands there's
really not much difference behind the
simplification of the legal structure
and Ireland's we are actually going to
hire even more than
level of corporate governance we are
already rated at the highest grade by
ISS here in the UK but we are moving
behind this new structure to a one share
one fold we stop the pressures in the
Netherlands we still have a trust office
so it actually gets a corporate
governance annual elections of the board
that is at the highest levels that you
will see what about your membership of
the foods you 100 will this continue
under the single share structure will be
traded on the three indexes we will be
traded in New York in London on prime
listing and the euro and Exile in
Amsterdam the Fucci index is something
that we need to still talk now that we
have made the announcement the reality
is right now only half of the company
was traded in the Fuji the PLC part and
half of the company was traded on the ax
which was the envy part now
consolidating that into one obviously
there is a bigger trading in the
European index so we will pick up there
some things what we found was that
relatively few investors just trade the
Fuji index it's really up to investors
to decide in their investment we met
what what they will do and how they will
construct their portfolios and it's more
in their decision power than ours
obviously but does it matter to you if
you're not in the fuzzy we would we
would not mind being in the Fuji but I
don't think it is for our shareholders a
for most of our share all those are the
majority of our shareholders
a major reason there are companies in
the Fuji that are not headquartered in
the UK and we will be talking about some
of the possibilities there as well